my husband he said we're just like My
Big Fat Greek Wedding and I'm like
people look at him what are you talking
about and he says well you know American
guy Mary's Greek girl gets baptized
Greek Orthodox
this is one reunion we'll never forget
I'm Linda Carroll Trotter I was born in
Greece I was adopted by Americans and
this is the story of how I found My Big
Fat Greek family
hello I'm Perry nemeroff and welcome to
movie people where we meet passionate
fans whose favorite film or director
made a big impression on their lives
today we're in Franklin Tennessee diving
into the world of My Big Fat Greek
Wedding and learning about one
remarkable family reunion
I was born in the small Mountain Village
of stranma Greece I was given to the
orphanage in Athens when I was a month
and a half old and at eight months of
age I was adopted by Americans from San
Antonio Texas James and Ruth Forest
wonderful couple who love me very much
my dad he had a movie camera and he got
with his friends and said I want to film
this
I'm the only Greek adoptee that I know
of that actually has a film of them
arriving from Greece
I grew up in a kind and loving
environment had all the advantages
anyone could ever hope to have but I
really didn't have much exposure to
anything Greek did you want to see some
brochures
what do you remember about the first
time you watched My Big Fat Greek
Wedding I went to see with my husband
and I didn't know what to expect I
really had no real connection to my
culture before this franchise of movies
came out because my parents weren't
Greek and I wasn't raised around that so
went to the movie and I'm just amazed
because it's the way I can connect to
that culture and Heritage that I missed
being in a Big Fat Greek family because
My Big Fat Greek Wedding was one big
family thing everybody was all in your
business and everybody's telling you
what to do and the father's squirting
Windex everywhere and I'm just like is
that really is that a thing you know I
mean and it was just my first foray into
really knowing that Greek culture like
underneath all of it more than just
superficially
when you were growing up how much did
you know about your biological family
my parents have been told that my
biological mother had died in childbirth
that I was premature baby that there was
no family to find and then when my
parents passed away my dad in 2015 and
my mom in 2017 I felt all alone again
like I was an orphan I didn't have any
brothers or sisters or anybody else to
lean on so I decided that regardless of
if there was anyone to find or not I was
going to see what I could find in my
homeland of Greece did some internet
searches and among other things and in a
short period of about three months I
amazingly found my Greek biological
family in Greece with my biological
mother still alive at the age of 80.
[Music]
I was worried before the plane landed it
was gonna is it gonna be weird is going
to be awkward are they going to feel
like family are going to feel like
strangers what's this going to be like
because you're really walking into the
unknown without knowing really what's
happening so when I hugged her and my
cousins and everybody else that was
there it just felt normal they felt like
family because they are my family and it
was an amazing experience
the wedding scene in the movie is so
iconic so did you ever want to have your
very own a Big Fat Greek Wedding when
they had the actual wedding scene it was
very emotional for me because I had
never really seen what a Greek Wedding
looked like I was just fascinated by the
whole thing and how symbolic it was and
I love the crowns the Stefania with the
walking around the altar three times and
how that's you take your first steps as
man and wife together and that just
really touched me when our 25th wedding
anniversary was looming in the distance
I got this crazy idea that you know I
might have had to wait 25 years for My
Big Fat Greek Wedding but I'm gonna get
one how about we renew our wedding vows
on the platea The Village Square in our
village where I was born with my
biological mother who missed all the
milestones in my life missed my wedding
missed my kids birth missed everything
and let's have a Greek touch to it let's
have the crowns the Stefania let's do
all of that so that's what we did
[Music]
we all gathered on the platia with about
50 of our family and we renewed our
wedding vows and then we used the crowns
these are the Stefania and I made them
myself and we got to do kind of our own
little Big Fat Greek Wedding
[Applause]
do you think there's going to be any
similarities between the porticolas
family reunion and your very own I know
in the trailer for My Big Fat Greek
Wedding three that Tula is talking to
some distant cousin or something to her
they meet when they get off the plane at
the airport because everybody in Greece
is related to each other they're sitting
at the table talking and two let's hold
up to picture of her father's friends I
know them do they still live here no how
do we find them they will come for the
reunion did they tell you they're coming
no and I said oh my gosh that reminds me
of my family when we planned the wedding
anniversary party I sent out invitations
I said artist VP please tell us if
you're coming and how many people so a
week before I still nobody has rsvp'd no
one not a single person and so I'm
calling my family are you coming yes
yeah that's a week from now of course
we're coming we don't need to tell you
now typical typical I am surprised but I
am not surprised
because I'm never surprised how does it
feel to have an entire film franchise
celebrating your culture especially one
that's gone on to be hugely successful
that's written and now also directed by
a Greek woman it's a pretty amazing
thing because people have preconceived
ideas about Greek people or all they
know is something about ancient Greece
or mythology or philosophy or medicine
because of you know Socrates and
Hippocrates but I don't think anybody
really understands the intricacies of
family in Greece and how Greek families
actually interact with each other to
have a franchise celebrate that
especially for someone like me who had
no exposure to a Greek family the whole
time I was growing up and to see that on
a big screen it just makes you have this
sense of pride in your heart that this
is your people these are my people and
they're being celebrated in an amazing
way all over the globe
how did your own story Inspire the work
you do my journey to find my roots in
Greece was more amazing than I ever
thought it could possibly be and I never
realized how much finding that piece of
my identity that was missing how
important that was and how much it would
mean to me so when I experienced the joy
of finding the peace and the closure and
the sheer amazement of finding my Greek
biological family I wanted every other
greek-born adoptee to have the same
thing that I did so the idea for the
here project was born and I didn't name
it the F the Kia project because my name
is f vikia i named it that because
ethicia means happiness so we're
basically the Happiness Project we're a
non-profit that assistant support Greek
born adoptees searching for their roots
and Greek families in Greece who are
searching for their children that were
lost to adoption for me it's just a
labor of love and a way to give back to
to my country another thing that touches
me about My Big Fat Greek Wedding three
is the fact that their journey is back
to Greece to go to Gus's ancestral
Village to get back in touch with their
Roots which is basically what I did I
journeyed to my little village of
stranoma and and came to my roots all of
these Greek adoptees that we assist and
help they want to also find the same
thing we only want what non-adopted
people take for granted they know where
they came from but we don't we're
leaving for Greece again on Tuesday I
can't wait to get on that plane and get
to Greece and see my family and then
when we're all there together I'm hoping
My Big Fat Greek Wedding 3 comes to our
little Cinema and not pothos and we can
all go see it together that would be
amazing
that's a wrap on this edition of movie
people I hope you enjoyed meeting Linda
Carroll Trotter and hearing her story of
finding her biological family for
another epic family reunion you'll want
to check out My Big Fat Greek Wedding 3
in theaters on September 8th
together
[Music]